[Music]
hey i'm kendy this is little light
studios and you're watching i got a
question today's question is
what does it matter if i watch whatever
i want
well what matters are the effects it has
on your body mind and spirit we have so
many videos that go in depth with this
i'll link some of them below but for now
let's do some rapid fire predictive
programming do not conform to the
pattern of this world
but be transformed by the renewing of
your mind
then you will be able to test and
approve what god's will is
his good pleasing and perfect well
romans 12 2
trauma
jesus tells us in matthew 5 28 but i
tell you that anyone who looks at a
woman lustfully has committed adultery
with her in his heart the brain cannot
distinguish between just watching versus
actually doing the action
the person who pulls the trigger and the
person who watches the trigger being
pulled both walk away scarred
disingenuous christianity
not everyone who says to me lord lord
will enter the kingdom of heaven
but only the one who does the will of my
father who is in heaven
matthew 7 21 cognitive dissonance
although they know god's righteous
decree that those who do such things
deserve death
they not only continue to do these very
things but also approve of those who
practice them
romans 1 32 mixing what doesn't match
for what do righteousness and wickedness
have in common or what fellowship can
light have with darkness what harmony is
there between christ and belial
accepting jesus into our hearts makes us
children of light
why would we then chase after darkness
so what does it matter if you watch
listen or engage in whatever you want
well
what matters is obedience and protecting
your body temple as best you can through
the help of jesus
hey thanks for the question and don't be
shy to reach out your question might be
the next one that we answer
now if you like these short videos
answering your media related questions
please leave a like and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you